فِي مَنْزِلِ أُنْثَى السِّنْجَابْ دَقَّ دَقَّ البَابْ
دق دق دق ، مَنْ بِالْبَابْ؟
محبوب وبجسمي صوف *** شكلي به يبدو مألوف
وهنا بالمزرعة أطوف
أهلا بك أهلا يا خروف  *** أهلا يا أغلى الاحباب
هيا اسمع مأمأتك    ***   وسنفتح في الحال الباب
(ميووو ميووو)
هذا ليس بصوت خروف   *** اذهب اذهب يا كذاب
ما دامت ماما بالخارج   ***   لن ندخل أبدا أغراب
في منزل أنثى السنجاب *** دق دق الباب
دق دق دق من بالباب؟
بلطافتي جئت أحييكم  *** أشهى ألبان أعطيكم
بالطاقة دوما تغنيكم
أهلا أهلا يا بقرة *** أهلا يا أغلى الاحباب
هيا نسمع صوت خوارك *** وسنفتح في الحال الباب
(كااااك كاااااك)
هذا ليس بصوت البقرة *** اذهب اذهب يا كذاب
ما دامت ماما بالخارج *** لن ندخل أبدا أغراب
في منزل أنثى السنجاب *** دق دق الباب
دق دق دق من بالباب؟
كالنمر لكني أليفة  *** في قفزي حركاتي خفيفة
وأنا مع الإنسان لطيفة
أهلا أهلا يا قطة *** أهلا يا أغلى الاحباب
هيا نسمع صوت موائك *** وسنفتح في الحال الباب
(بااااااع بااااااع)
هذا ليس بصوت القطة  ***  اذهب اذهب يا كذاب
ما دامت ماما بالخارج ***   لن ندخل أبدا أغراب
فِي مَنْزِلِ أُنْثَى السِّنْجَابْ دَقَّ دَقَّ البَابْ
دق دق دق ، مَنْ بِالْبَابْ؟
أمشي تتبعني صيصاني ***   دوما أغمرهم بحناني
في الخم لنا عيش هاني
أهلا أهلا يا دجاجة  ***    أهلا يا أغلى الاحباب
هيا نسمع صوت نقيقك ***   وسنفتح في الحال الباب
(موووووو موووووو)
هذا ليس بصوت دجاجة ***    اذهب اذهب يا كذاب
ما دامت ماما بالخارج ***     لن ندخل أبدا أغراب
في منزل أنثى السنجاب *** دق دق الباب
دق دق دق من بالباب؟
أنا قدوتكم في الوفاء *** أحرسكم من الأعداء
افتحوا صاحبكم قد جاء
أهلا أهلا يا ثعلب ***  أهلا أهلا يا كذاب
لن تفلت هذي المرة ***   وستأخذ أقسى العقاب
النجدة
في منزل أنثى السنجاب *** دق دق الباب
فِي مَنْزِلِ أُنْثَى السِّنْجَابْ دَقَّ دَقَّ البَابْ